hello
my name is markiplier and welcome to the
next step in my quest to find the game
that allows me to kill the most zombies
possible
this is
they are billions
this game is fascinating because it
doesn't lie
this number here this number here is the
total infected killed i've killed 370
000 but collectively across the player
base there have been 704 billion zombies
killed which is strange because that
should be more than there are people
especially in this steampunk era but
what i'm gonna do is i'm not gonna play
the campaign i'm not gonna play any of
that i'm gonna play this thing called
creative defense now this is a custom
map they recently like last year allowed
custom maps or maybe they've always had
it they had modding rules and whatever
this is a perfect example of how i'm
going to die there's no way that i'm
going to win this because i'm not nearly
good enough at this game to even get
close to winning like i don't know what
the hell i'm doing with this game but
all i know is that there are a lot of
zombies and that's all i care about so
it's basically like a base building game
right it's base building whatever is
base building you build a base
but
and then made by that guy i get some of
those
i don't even know how to access those
because for some reason i'm an idiot
this is what i get for not like um
understanding what i'm doing and just
jumping in not even remotely
understanding uh what the intricate game
mechanics are for those of you who have
played this game please forgive me i'm
going to be bad at this and i'm gonna
attempt to do things right but i'm gonna
do a lot of things wrong okay so just so
you all know and just so we get that out
of the way this is going to be
painful for people that are good at this
game but it's a good example of why this
game satisfies my itch to kill
so many zombies if you remember from my
previous video a lot of zombies this one
has
billions of zombies i want my computer
to melt from the sheer number of zombies
that will appear and this custom map
satisfies that itch because they all
come from this left side and all funnel
down right here okay everyone following
good because i'm not going to explain it
again the other thing to do is you gotta
make a lot of soldiers right
or
i don't know maybe that's the right
strategy i don't know
it hurts her fish
okay so if you don't know what that's
doing don't even worry about it
what i'm doing is very important and
shut up i'll tell you in just a moment
hold on
hush so the reason i did this
is because i want to make a lot of
soldiers because
there are like i said
billions of zombies that's not an
exaggeration
why would i exaggerate i wouldn't
i don't those are getting completed okay
that's probably not even enough you know
what i mean i probably should build more
these are like
these are you're not even supposed to be
able to build more than one of these but
it's a custom game mode so whatever it's
fine
oil production is too low oil production
is too low oh frick i forgot i need to
actually research i'm
not good at this game okay so what i
need to do is i need to build the
workshop so i can start researching
because i just don't have enough um but
in the meantime uh no i can't i gotta
wait till that's done building the
reason that i'm in a hurry is because on
day 14
everything is gonna go to hell in a hand
basket real fast and when i say real
fast lixie and show him a sneak peek of
what's coming for me oh my god okay
that's what's coming okay i gotta be
ready for that now i'm gonna pause
because i i
like i said
i'm not good at this game
yet i may become good in the future but
for right now i'm
not
so what i'm doing right here you a-hole
what i'm doing right here is i'm
building walls right so the green online
is just like these are gonna start
building soon um and then on along these
walls i'm building little towers
that i can put soldiers into and they
can shoot at the enemy that's the
objective here is to not die
understood so i'm trying to
not die okay
all right so those are getting built and
i still don't have enough soldiers i
don't have nearly enough soldiers i
should have snipers i guess snipers have
better long range ah man i'm already off
to a bad start okay workshop is not
built yet i am so behind on everything
uh there was a it's like they said
something in the beginning of this how
it like gave you free units but i
haven't figured out how to get those
units so i really don't know
how to do anything in this game
i really have no idea uh what i'm doing
but god this is fun it's just fun you
know it's it's just really really fun oh
i can oh there's free oil that's what i
was
what i was yeah i don't need the
research
you like the sound
so now that i have those building i'm
gonna build more of
these things because i just can't get
enough
screw it i was trying to be nice about
it i i don't have the time for that
the dog parking uh it's not enough okay
so the the fun thing is that i i'm
trying to get across to you guys is
that's not enough i cannot express how
not enough that is it really might seem
like it's enough it is
so not enough so i'm putting them up in
these turrets you can put four to a
thing think like starcraft bunkers
that's basically what these are okay
here we go this is more like it okay i
want canada's oh god i need more oil oh
my god okay this thing i think is it's
like some kind of a wonder that converts
things to oil i think that's what it
does i'm again not supposed to have that
many of those but i do okay all of you
go over there and okay this is much
better i am out of gold
no i'm not
there's it's there's unlimited gold in
this but uh it does it does give it
stuff back so i guess i don't need those
but whatever hell yeah
tannatus now this is what i am talking
about
now this is more light this is not what
i did the last time that i played this
and uh i have a feeling i'm going to do
a little bit better but not much because
again
it's
not enough
okay so what i'm doing is i'm loading up
this channel with these dudes because
they're basically artillery so they they
just stand there and they freaking blow
up
let's put this awesome body to use
okay how are we doing here more please
not enough
it's
not
enough staring at my muscles
who's this guy thinking is me all right
let's close up this gap here that's why
i have the gates there
oh that guy's
that guy's stuck as hell now let's
really cram them in here because trust
me it is
say it with me
not enough
okay
i'm pausing for a moment because i have
eight days left eight days and i am
still not where i want to be and i
forgot i needed to get the academy of
the immortal school
i'm very dumb you don't know what that
means but don't worry about it it's fine
stuff it in stuff it in cram it's like
uh it's like a like a train in tokyo
let's cram it in that's perfect that's
perfect actually that's perfect
you're gonna hold that position oh yeah
look at them all oh
it's not enough maybe i should just take
these gates out and let's put this off
i think yeah let me just keep i'm taking
these out and i'm just gonna replace
them with walls because
why not right really close them in these
guys are basically dead
like these are these guys are dead
there's there's no way that they're
gonna survive they're dead
wish them well but they are gone i'm
gonna literally
fill this whole thing with wires they
are now all standing on wires it's fine
they got boots it's it's fine don't
worry about it they're fine they like it
they like the wires ask them they like
them they like the wires trust me you'll
thank me for the wires later
when you see the billions of zombies oh
my god
uh what next what next what could i do
what could i do what could i do i could
shift gears to like snipers or something
i don't know i guess i could just put a
lot of stone towers maybe oh i could do
stone towers and then fill them with
snipers then they could probably hit
from here even if everything is
stopped up on the first layer walls
there they definitely could okay but
it'll be a bit before we get snipers
going okay cool now we're getting
snipers so snipers are good they're a
little little edge lordy but you know
they're pretty cool i guess either this
is a good idea or a terrible idea but i
feel like it's a good idea so i'm gonna
do it what's the worst that could happen
yeah that feels good let's do it
sweet now what that did is it made these
guys all yellow and everyone knows
zombies hate the color yellow
okay this feels pretty good you know
this feels like i might have a bit of a
better shot it's day nine i have five
days left until i die horribly did i
mention that there are billions of
zombies that are coming after me oh my
god
take these guys and we're gonna
literally cram them in every nook and
cranny of this maze of
of things
just cram them full these guys are a
little excess i i didn't need this many
snipers but
i mean i i it's not enough i might as
well have them but like let me tell you
i didn't plan i don't have like a plan
for him but just saying i i don't have
an immediate use for him but any use is
not enough i think i've stuffed them
okay i'm gonna hold position there we go
there we go all right that's stuffed in
there okay what can i do i have i have
four days left i have three days left
actually because i'm not paying
attention and i don't actually have as
many days as i think let's put spikes
underneath here
wherever we can okay
um
let's call that the first line of
defense let's take these guys and i'm
gonna cram them right here these guys oh
god why did i pick from that side any
orders i'm gonna cram these guys in here
okay all right we'll cram everyone in
just cram them in you know what just
cram them just cram them in was this a
letter cram them in just cram them in
it's the best we can do let's cram them
cram in there everybody cramming keep
going keep cramming in there
perfect keep going perfect
this is wonderful and everybody hold
okay this is perfect it's not perfect
but it feels perfect
and they're gonna be there forever i
don't care they're gonna die
now you can't put walls three in a row
for some reason you have to keep them
separated
or can you
weird okay that makes sense
oh no ah god damn it i didn't mean to do
that
okay more tanatus
and then i'm just gonna have these guys
producing uh soldiers till the end of
their days
okay
i don't know what else i can do to
prepare i seem to be capping out on the
amount of oil that i have
let's hold these guys there great and
then you guys are just gonna be making
those till the ends of your days and uh
oh boy it's day thirteen oh yay okay oh
yay okay maybe i can make more sanitis
maybe i should make something else let's
try titans i guess i wonder if i could
if i should just build another wall i
don't know if it'll do anything because
at this point like if they get through
that
then uh
i think i'm kind of boned well let's try
anyway
because i have some time and i don't
want to say that i didn't try
everything um maybe we could put
uh these wasps things which is like a
little mini turret
well we have titans so that's cool
all right i didn't have this much the
last time i tried this but
i failed like on day
and you gotta get to 21 and day 21 is
when the actual swarm comes so
everything before that is just like a
teaser
uh so i don't know
oh oh oh god oh it started oh god
okay that's gonna be annoying
okay
um so yeah this is uh this is the what i
was telling you uh god shut up why now
it's the fanfare for the oh
the fanfare for the beginning of that oh
my god
oh my god oh it's not enough oh it's not
enough
oh it's so not enough oh god it's not
enough oh they've already broken through
oh my god welcome to they are billions
you know how i kept saying that there
was gonna be
billions
um
yeah that's what happened you can see my
computer's kind of taking a little bit
of a dump that's okay
you zoom in nice and close you get to
see all the action there's an infected
chubby
bam dead affected venom
that's a harpy
actually it seems to be holding
relatively okay i thought that that was
gonna cave like nothing and they were
just gonna plow right through but
actually that
that kind of held up that that didn't go
as bad as i thought i mean there's still
like an infinite amount but that didn't
do as bad as i thought it was going to
do
all right that's the sound of people
dying but that's all right that's fine
it's fine don't worry about it just
gonna cram these guys here hold position
there you're the last line of defense
literally that's cool though that's cool
that's so cool look at them all
look at them all well they lost a few
little walls there that's kind of
shocking
what
no way
well kick my ass
screw it walls
just walls put up walls yeah i i made it
past this one before and then uh the
next one got me so i'm not gonna
celebrate just yet but hey
that went
pretty good i don't know if these are
gonna get built in time only a few more
days left to survive uh can i like what
if i put leg
oh my god here they come they're coming
oh god these are giants uh they're big
boys they're real real big boys
they're really big boys
yeah they don't like walls whoa
whoa
and still life takes a lot of punishment
oh boy yeah those did not get built in
time
well you know wishful thinking wishful
thinking wishful thinking
actually know they're not doing too bad
i'm not doing too bad
killing those guys ooh
hey some of them did get built
shocking
oh my god the leg
oh my god
it's so laggy
oh this is everything i could have
possibly wanted there's everything i
could wanted this is what i've always
wanted if there was a first person
shooter that had this many zombies and
it was like a hundred people on your
team and you were all trying to stop the
zombies from coming in that would be the
best game
that would be an incredible game i would
love that game i really love shooting
a lot of zombies i love the idea of that
game oh can you imagine that this many
zombies a hundred people on your team
and you're just trying your best like oh
that sounds so fun
well it doesn't exist so whatever
my god the lag
go okay now i'm starting to lose yeah
now i'm starting to die
now things are going down
oh yeah now they're gonna start carving
through
man this is going slow
oh
my
god
oh my god
it's just a wall of blood and
okay the lag's clearing up a little bit
i seem to be winning
at least i've only lost this much which
i consider a victory
i don't know why but i just told him to
attack the highest level i assume that
that might be good yeah because if the
snipers are killing the tough ones then
the the thanatos
might be able to clear out these little
guys
if they're just aiming for them
wow
[Music]
i'm actually
very impressed holy crap
i'm gonna just load it with wasps and
hope that they build in time
okay all right that that
hopefully that adds a lot of uh
firepower that helps even the odds i
guess
oh oh oh god here they come oh that was
much sooner than i thought it'd be i
thought i'd have some time
i thought i'd have time okay i did have
time okay that's good that's good hey
look at that
hey
that's pretty good
oh that's
helpful that's helpful
i i've never made it this far so i i i
don't know how far i'm gonna go or how
much wow okay never mind it's getting
now okay it's very bad it's very bad
it's very bad it's very bad
very bad these do nothing oh god they do
nothing oh god they do nothing i thought
that was gonna be just a little bit
better but apparently not okay all right
what keeping them at bay okay all right
keeping them at bay a bit
a little at bay at michael bay with the
number of explosions but kind of keeping
them at bay just uh they broke through
oh no they broke through here i think i
can't tell under all of the explosions
my god that's a just a wall of fire god
will it be enough though that's the
question will it be enough boy was that
was that kind of naive with this one
line of wasps like yeah that'll take
care of it yeah that'll be fine yeah oh
yeah oh no they're starting the process
has begun it's a day 18 which means that
technically speaking i'm getting close
to the end but also i have a funny
feeling that i'm
getting close to the end which
the end being my death yeah my my first
line of thanatos is gonna crumble soon
so
the wall of fire shall uh succumb and i
have a funny feeling that when the wall
of fire kind of stops i kind of stop
breathing oh they just keep coming
they just
ah they just keep coming don't they okay
it's not eroding as quickly as i thought
it was going to i mean don't get me
wrong i'm dying
but not as much as i suspected
okay they're they're thinning ah unless
i'm crazy it's thinning out
and i might be crazy but i think they're
thinning out which means that my
cavalcade of snipers in towers of which
there's only three in that one oh no
four three
might have worked
oh no they're thickening
they were thinning and now they're
thickening okay well i guess uh the real
swarm is almost here so uh frankly i
thought that i was um i thought i was
doing well but apparently not i cannot
believe this is holding up as well it
has i thought that as soon as this wall
broke that this would just start falling
apart i mean it is kind of but also not
okay it's really starting to fall apart
now oh that's a big hefty wall that's a
heavy wall of hefties
oh that guy oh that was the last guy in
that corner there oh no
oh god die well friends die well die
well
go out in a blaze of glory
die in glory
uh and there he goes okay all right um
oh is this just like the calm before the
storm of uh
the main bunch of them
because it says six hours until the
bubble come
uh but uh at least this is uh
this is cleared out
i i can't believe this worked out as
well as it did i i am stunned
i am stunned i have also i have this
entire truckload of soldiers here
there's more soldiers than i ever could
have imagined
i don't know what this final wave is
gonna be but i got a bad feeling about
it oh look at that oh good frame rate oh
that's fascinating
oh it's good
oh it's great
oh my god
oh goodbye
oh that's what you meant by dying glory
oh god oh god oh god oh god
they're so big
okay well all right oh yeah oh
oh wow yeah no
oh no
oh no okay
[Music]
oh boy i'm not killing any of them or if
i am i can't even tell
oh you just chewed through those okay
that didn't
i thought that was gonna last a little
longer but uh
i guess not
oh wow
[Music]
is
i uh
[Music]
i have no idea how oh my
god oh
they get munched
oh
no
oh they could turn to paul
oh
now
[Music]
so there you have it
that is they are billions and i guess
they don't need billions if they just
have a couple million of those big guys
that's their billions i like this game i
like it a lot it's very fun if you want
to play links is in the description
thank you everybody so much for watching
um if you've succeeded in that level uh
congratulations you're better at this
game than i am i am not sure what i
could have done differently they kind of
just seemed to melt through walls i
guess i could have tried a little harder
but
i don't know okay but thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought in the comments
below and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you